I'm always curious man being uh gay in
the hip-hop industry yeah it's obviously
a very homophobic uh genre of music
historically yeah because the rapper's
sucking dick ain't gonna tell you
they're not gonna tell you that these
[__] out here sucking dick [__]
trans they're not gonna tell you these
[__] out here [__] and you
know what they never really [__] with me
because one I think I mean of course I'm
cute I'm well dressed I'm rich and by
the way you're 45 and you're you're 45.
black don't crack God bless you black
does crack when you're broke okay black
don't crack when you got a good
dermatologist well you look great thank
you but the thing about it is I mean my
career is [__] off my dating
opportunity in the hip-hop Community
because these [__] Ain't Gonna slide
them ideas because they know like or
they don't know they assume that I'm
gonna put them on blast which if they
follow me I don't out people I don't
attack children and you know um there's
one more thing I can't think of but you
know there's just some certain things
that I don't do but
um I know that a lot of reasons why some
of these hip-hop artists don't call my
show is they have skeletons and they
think that